i really don't like the jj abrams star
trek movies and here's why
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
right
i would actually argue straight off the
bat
these movies aren't star trek the jj
abrams films if they'd have called the
enterprise the endeavor
set in the same time frame as kirk and
spock and so on but change the character
names have the same actors but have a
different vulcan a different
unhappy captain a different scottish
engineer actually could have just
changed him to an english engineer and
then we wouldn't have had to put up with
that awful scottish accent but
we'll ignore that
but no they had to create a sequel we
had to have kirkback and spock back and
scotty back and everybody else it had to
be aboard a massive enterprise which is
one of my first unforgivable things
this these series of movies peel over
cannon constantly and one of the things
they did was made the enterprise massive
it's even bigger than the enterprise e
now
star trek fans like myself are complete
geeks we love the technology we love the
details of star trek it's science
fiction the science part
specific measured matters
in this series they just made the
enterprise absolutely enormous because
jj abrams thought it would look better
on imax and that annoys me
so
first thing i might list here characters
and canon
they absolutely wiped canon out with
this film and they used the time travel
scenario as an excuse to be able to
change everything they basically said
from this point when nero arrived and
killed captain kirk's father they
changed history therefore we're in a
different timeline it's the kelvin
timeline so we can do whatever we want
no
why
why you don't have to do that the
universe is a big place just do a
different pigging story a different ship
then you don't have to peel over cannon
and wind everybody up but also then if
you do change the characters at least
let it make sense now we're going to
talk the black hole in a second but
let's just actually talk about things
that are really basic like
why does
captain pike find james t kirk getting
his butt kicked in a bar
basically kirk at this point is a
complete loser he's been a criminal most
his life from what we can tell
but pike sees something in him
what we don't know but he sees something
in him he tells him why do you join
starfleet so kirk just turns up the next
day and gets aboard the shuttle
leaves his motorbike gives some plug the
keys fair enough guess we'll shuttle i'm
if i be pike i'll be like uh there is
some admin work to do here you can't
just get aboard
and then when he does go through the
academy he cheats on the kobayashi maru
which again peedled over canon and
actually ruined a really good fact a
really good part of the original series
that cheated in the kobayashi maru
they just did that in the most pathetic
way and really ruined that for me
but then he gets a board thing and they
apparently when you leave starfleet
academy you just become random ranks
and join random ships um you can become
a first officer straight out of the
academy apparently
no
how did kirk become captain within like
a week of leaving the academy it doesn't
make any sense and that is so
infuriating as me who i am a trekkie i
love the detail of these things
make it make sense for the love of all
that's holy
talk about things not making sense let's
talk about
science fiction for a second it's
science fiction but the important word
there is science so let's not have
nonsensical science in the series
black holes cannot be used to travel
through time not like a big hole in
space it's actually not a big hole in
space even though at another point we do
see a black hole being created that
actually destroys everything it touches
you know it appears within vulcan and
just wipes everything out i don't know
why they had to drill a hole down to
vulcan's core to do that they could have
just dropped that red matter on the
surface and it would have done exactly
the same thing but you know we wouldn't
have that cool parachuting onto the
drill scene and everything so you know
we don't have to be take two things too
seriously but you know i'd like it to
make some sense
so the black hole there wipes them for
that destroys everything but then in the
second scene nero can fly through like
it's a hole in space like it's spaceship
you know spock's spaceship comes flying
through 20 years later
it doesn't make any sense
nero so my nero for a second he travels
back in time before romulus is destroyed
he could spend his time doing something
about that
helping romulus maybe prevent the
catastrophe from happening in the first
place or very least tell the romulans
they could evacuate but he decides not
to do that he decides just to hang
around for 20 years and wait for spock
to appear so he can go on a bit of a
vengeance rant
it doesn't make any sense
why would he do that
the red matter
in spock ship doesn't make any sense why
is there so much of it when only a
single drop is all you need
again makes no picking sense
scientifically it makes no sense
then spock and kirk have an argument
aboard the enterprise and spock kicks
kirk off he lands on a nice planet that
just happens to be within walking
distance
of spock and scotty
spock then gives scotty transwarp
equations so we can do trans warp
transporting right now all of a sudden
we have transporters that basically
means basic starships are completely
unnecessary completely redundant
technology because you can just beam
anywhere in the next film into darkness
obviously khan does
so why are we still running around
starships if this technology is so
freely available that a terrorist can
get his hands on one
and also the technology isn't even that
complicated
khan's version is a shoe box right that
big
it carries the technology in a suitcase
so no
that makes no sense also spark when he
gives
scotty the transwarp technology
basically says keep saying that he can't
tell you too much because it will change
the future but here is game-changing
technology that will change everything
just because we needed to move the story
along
while we're mentioning khan
how thick is he
he's trying to hide his 72
friends basically so what do you do put
them in a torpedo
how does that make any sense how did he
not know that the bloody commander
admiral wasn't going to start
test-firing a few of these idiots
i actually love the khan character i
actually think the wrath of khan is one
of the greatest star trek movies ever
made undiscovered country is actually my
personal favorite but that's because i
it was the first film i ever saw the
cinema the starting sequence is amazing
but actually if i'm being unhonest wrath
of khan is probably the better film
they kind of ruin that benedict
cumberbatch is a great actor he loved
overplaying this character but the one
scene where he's in the glassell and he
loudly announces that his name is really
con
made no sense they don't know who khan
is the other guy is scotty or whatever
they're just standing there going who
so
you know it's just like
it's just it's just a very strange
moment that was basically for us and not
for anybody else and really didn't make
any sense it was for us because we all
already knew it was horribly leaked and
basically because they just keep trying
to remake the original star treks anyway
that you know we all know it was just
stupid
um the whole end sequence is i shall
always be your friend as well that was
nowhere near as good oh and by the way
khan's blood apparently is magic
kirk wasn't sick at the end of that film
he was dead
and khan's blood regenerated him
now i'm not a bit confused about how the
science of that works but basically now
death isn't a problem anymore apparently
because we've got khan's blood if we can
recreate that
all you would ever need to do is have a
vial of cars blood in on you at any
point and you just go oh god i've lost a
leg inject i'm fine
in the third movie
the hive ships an intracellular
character
none of that made sense where did you
get the hive ships from it's incredibly
powerful piece of technology now even
though
the scene when the franklin is coming
along and it's sweep across and all the
hype ships are exploding looked
incredible
beastie boys blown along
peanuts beaming the beastie boys song
disrupted them and they all crashed into
each other and think
why would you actually need the song
again make no sense i i i wouldn't mind
one or two of these problems
but all of them
all of them
it's at some point you just have to
cross the line and go this is crap
this is a lot of nonsense another thing
is in the original star trek movies if
you start picking them apart you can
find problems in the tv series they
contradict each other at times there are
these things that happen but we ignore
it because sometimes it's necessary for
the story
the problem i have for the jj abrams
films it's because jt image doesn't seem
to have had any respect for the movies
he doesn't seem to have any respect for
star trek
now
there are lots of these things that he
did that he didn't need to
he didn't need to make the enterprise
massive he didn't need to mess around
with the warp calls so they made no
scientific sense
there's one no there's six there's
nothing it again made no sense
there are lots and lots of things in the
story the characters and so on that they
didn't need to do and they did because
they look good or because it moved the
story along
and that is the reason why
very clearly i say
these aren't star trek films
if you watch them
change the name of the enterprise to
something like the endeavour in your
head change kirk's name to kenneth
change spock to norman change the names
in your head
watch the films you'll thoroughly enjoy
them as action-packed funny
enjoyable movies
but as a trekkie with your trekkie head
on
god they're annoying
right get into the comments tell me what
you think what is the most annoying part
of the jj abrams star trek movies for
you
what are the parts that movies you
actually love and am i just talking
rubbish am i just overthinking it and
complaining about nothing are they
actually really good films and i should
just let it go
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out you
can actually join the channel too and
for a small amount of money each month
help me to produce more content also get
into the comments and tell me what sort
of things you want to see on future
videos
also you can join us on facebook there
is a link in the description thanks very
much guys and as always stay safe i'll
see you really soon
you